[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show it's
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life your work
your relationships your money i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague george
campbell and we're here together for you
this hour it's a free phone call to jump
in it's all about you we want to help
you with breakthrough triple eight eight
two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five how you doing pal
just glorious ken you're glorious it's
80 degrees and sunny in nashville yeah i
didn't ask you that i didn't ask you
that but thank you for the weather let's
be in a good mood oh does it you're in a
good mood okay great how about we help
some people you ready for that i'm ready
he's glorious folks he's ready and
christian is ready he's on the line in
raleigh north carolina christian how can
we help
hey how you doing we are having a blast
and george is glorious
yeah well i'm 21 years old
i'm about to graduate college on the 7th
of may
and i have some debt and i'm trying to
figure out the best way to pay it off
awesome well george can help let's do
this thing so how much debt are we
talking
i have 27 000 in student loans and about
11 000 on a car payment
okay what's the car worth
uh the car's worth about 32. whoa
what kind of car is it
uh it's a 2017 gmc sierra yeah wow
21 year old driving that's a nice car
man so do you have a job right now
yes sir i i work part-time and i'm a
full-time student
and i saved enough to put a hefty down
payment on it but
the job i have lined up after college
will be about
3 500 a month for my income is that
take-home pay or is that gross
that's uh that's take-home okay
what kind of what kind of field is this
what job
uh computer science awesome well that's
got a lot of room for growth if you're
in that career path
i'd like to hear that so
do you know what your plans are once you
graduate are you moving are you staying
put are you renting
uh staying at home for a few years so
the only expenses i have are the student
loans and the car payments okay what do
you mean by a few years what's the the
timeline for that based on
um i don't really have a plan for that
but
i'm planning on staying home
for at least two years
okay is that to pay off the debt faster
or
uh yes sir and also my job is only 15
minutes from my house
where i'm currently staying so
it's just easier commute
okay so you're going to be bringing home
about 42 000 a year and what i want you
to do when you graduate and you step
into that job is to continue living like
a broke college kid
and get this debt out of your life as
soon as possible uh do you know what
your student loan payments are going to
be
the minimum is about 300 a month but
there's also a
benefit with
my job where they'll pay me 250
additional
to pay off the student loans every month
so i would only be paying 50 a month
yeah so my plan was with the snowball
would be just throw everything i have at
the car payment until that's done and
then throw everything at student loans
until that's done okay well here if i'm
in your shoes and that's how i answer
calls here i'm selling that car
okay i think it's just too much car for
you right now yeah and the fact that you
can get that much for it and you could
almost be out of debt if you sold that
thing right you said it would sell for
32.
yes sir and you have 11 on it which
leaves you
with just a nice chunk of change there
to get rid of those student loans which
you could then do with what six months
maybe
yes sir what kind of transportation
would you need
if you sell that car um oh that's the
that's the only form of vehicle i have
so i would just have to get something
else
all right so you you would have how much
george was left so you said you'd sell
for 32 you owe 11. that would leave you
with 21.
and so i'm gonna buy five thousand
dollars five six thousand dollar beater
car for now yeah this is not forever no
but for right now as a 21 year old
you'll be okay
and uh you do that and you'll have six
thousand left over yeah uh
21 so subtract the five you'd pay on the
car that still leaves you about 16 000
to throw at the student loans oh man
which takes you down to 11 on the
student loans that's great and you if
you could throw you know a thousand
bucks a month 2000 bucks a month you're
living at home right you have no
expenses
yes sir
i like this plan and my plan would be to
move out
way faster than two years
when those loans are done and you've got
an emergency fund in place i'm gonna fly
the coop and i'm gonna get my own place
and rent and then begin the work of you
know saving up for a down payment if
that's what you want to do
okay so i mean right now i have an
emergency fund of about two grand from
part-time work
okay
so i'm just so do i need to save anymore
or should i just throw everything i have
at the loans
loans paid off and then start saving i
would cut that down to a thousand so i
take the thousand that's going to help
get rid of those loans even faster
on top of whatever you have after buying
a new beater car and that's going to
speed up the process even faster and
once you do that we're not talking two
years until you have a big savings
account we're talking
eight months maybe
yeah
so put this plan on paper
yes
man you can make that kind of money on
that car right now as a guy who's just
starting out his career trust me you're
going to be driving nicer cars later in
life but right now if you continue to
live like a broke college student you
will be unbelievably wealthy yeah and by
the way i want to point out a
relationship aspect here 21 year old you
know he's graduating the ladies don't
care about the car as much as you think
they do no my wife stacey and i are
about ready to celebrate to 24 years of
marriage and when we started dating i
was driving a mazda626 with 200 and who
knows how many miles on it 200 000 and
it was such a piece of crap that i would
to make her laugh on dates i would pull
the key out of the ignition while i was
driving and show her the keys was she
impressed no oh but she laughed that's
the point is she she she didn't care
yeah she didn't care about the car i
drove the car i had in high school i
drove for a decade yeah it wasn't long
ago that i finally you won big with the
ladies too so oh yeah you know
they don't call me george's lady killer
camel for nothing oh there it is no
i was invisible to girls in high school
yeah it panned out but yeah it worked
out great so the point is is on this
deal it's like when you can sell the car
certainly in times like this because
this is applicable to a lot of people
listening and watching right now hot car
market hot car market if you can get rid
of that debt by selling it
uh it's a temporary move
but i'm telling you i'm in the market
right now i've been telling you this
uh for my kid yeah and i'm not gonna
sink a lot of money into it because he
didn't take me up on the challenge
however much you make i'll match
so now i'm going i'm gonna get him
something that's serviceable
but if he if he runs it into a tree or a
guardrail you know what i mean i'm not
going to be like all but a lot of
parents they go well junior needs to
drive a safe reliable car so they go by
junior a 35 000 brand new car right
finance yeah let me tell you what self
ludicrous we think about safe and
reliable something that costs about four
or five grand that you know it's an old
toyota honda something like that you
know what i mean parts aren't that
expensive you take good care of it who
cares what it looks like it's safe and
reliable you know the truth is i think a
lot of parents their reputation's on the
line when junior's driving the beater
car around oh and they want to look good
yeah and let me tell you something
george you're absolutely right parents
stop making your kid's car one of your
status symbols college kids don't need
to be driving 30 40 000 cars no that's
not our opinion that's facts well they
want to go out and make the money then
go for it junior i like that all right
tell you what else i like we're just
getting started
more of your calls right around the
corner it's a free call triple eight
eight two five five two two five this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show where we
help you win
with your money your work and your
relationships george campbell joining me
i'm ken coleman ramsey personalities as
we take your calls this hour triple
eight eight two five five two two five
the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five all right speaking of money george
and and budgets and and boy you're the
guy
uh
it's very kind saw a story on yahoo
about jessica simpson
joking that she's on a budget what is
this all about i'm just as confused as
you can but it's a fun little piece here
jessica simpson jokes that she's on a
budget after her credit card got denied
at a taco bell you can't make this stuff
that's awkward this is there's a lot
going on here like are you surprised
that she went to taco bell there's
there's a lot of things i'm surprised
about here yeah she strikes me as a
wendy's uh fan really yeah i don't know
why okay i don't see jessica simpson in
taco bell yeah you know like what is she
getting there if you go into a taco bell
drive-through it is the most beautiful
melting pot of economics i mean there's
that right there's people in you know
sports cars wealthy folks okay it does
know this
taco bell you know does not discriminate
everyone loves them some late night
tacos and so does jessica simpson so
there she is the article opens jessica
simpson has some beef with taco bell
the artist 41 joked about having her
credit card declined at the popular fast
food chain while focusing her finances
on her ever-growing businesses as she
appeared this week on the reel quote i
have no working credit card simpson said
it's okay i'll pay in cash i went to
taco bell the other day and my card got
denied i'm on a budget ladies
that's a great quote right there she
added that she's draining my bank
account into growing her eponymous
billion dollar fashion brand of which
she and her mother tina regained control
of in october the multi-hyphenate even
considered borrowing against her home
for the big business move oh boy okay
that's confusing you're on a budget but
you're also going further into debt yeah
i don't know if she is on a budget but i
know this george we all got to be on a
budget when you don't have a reality tv
show very there's some confusing things
here she's got the cash to pay for taco
bell but the car is getting declined
yeah because she's got no credit be left
because she's spent it all on her she's
maxed it out her company she's maxed it
that's it thank you for using c i don't
even know the right words to use we'll
get there
but it's an interesting thing when you
look at you know celebrities and
finances because a lot of people go well
you know celebrities they're making so
much money they have it easy but a lot
of people who make really good money can
still be broke
it's fascinating how that works yeah so
i applaud jessica if she truly is on a
budget i think it's great and jessica if
you're listening uh my wife loved your
biography and we encourage you to check
out every dollar
that's what would you say if you were to
coach jessica simpson because a lot of
wealthy people blow their money they
don't do well would you have taco bell
in the budget
i think so you would yeah i mean
personally you know you allow for fast
food is a part of a budget i've got to
watch my physique ken personally as you
do too yeah you know at your age it
matters even
it matters even more wow this is good i
like this you know we talk about how if
you're trying to get out of debt we
don't want you to see the inside of a
restaurant and so that means you're not
eating out that's what i'm not frivolous
bringing it up and you're saying it's
okay well i think once you're out of
debt absolutely let's throw you know
throw it in the budget now i don't want
you eating out every single day mostly
because it's bad for your health on top
of your budget yeah uh but a little a
little taco bell never hurt anyone and
plus it's the cheapest way to buy gas
these days
taco bell dollar menu there you go again
there's my dad joke for the day oh man
there's so many ways i could go with
that it's only 1.19 to get gas at taco
bell dollar 19. yeah i'll tell you what
i don't know that if we can prove that
it's good for anybody though no but i do
want all celebrities and all normal
americans to be on a budget and to stay
away from debt so jessica don't borrow
against your home don't max out your
credit cards you are running this
fashion empire
use this revenue wisely we tell people
with entree leadership to run their
businesses completely debt-free yeah and
people say you can't do that ken but we
meet them every single year our entree
leadership events and they're amazing
business owners small business owners
who are running their businesses
completely debt free using cash
love to see it very interesting stuff
there you go would have loved to see
what that order was i'm just glad
yahoo's still around
it's amazing when you said that it was
like nostalgic to me yeah a lot going on
in my head i got jingles running through
my head the yahoo commercials talk about
i got the whole thing i'm trying to
refrain from friday yeah because i don't
want james rolling his eyes at me all
right to the phones we go stace is
joining us uh from kansas city missouri
stace how can we help
hello hello hi hi
you're on the ramsay show what's up you
made it
yay sorry i finally did hey um
you guys you do such great work i
can't even believe i'm on the phone with
you guys
um
so
um i
i'm in a bit of a mess um what's the
mess just tell us
huh it's hard to admit okay it's really
hard to admit no judgment or shame here
i
i have a credit card a couple credit
cards and um
before i
married my husband i
racked up some debt and
i haven't been able to pay them off
um
2019 i had my son
and um i didn't want to go back to work
so i am
raising my kids i'm a stay-at-home mom
and i don't have an income and
at least the one card knows this
that i mean i don't i'm not working
um
and i'm being sued by them
uh
well
uh
i i'm gonna butcher this guys i
gramaci and meyer
pc
what's the credit card company
um
capital one cabela's
we just took a call recently ken and it
was capital one apparently they're
notorious for suing people so just one
more reason to stay away from credit
cards but um
yeah a letter from a law firm there we
go ah there we go i'm writing slogans
while george is helping people so stace
what how much credit card debt is this
um it is two thousand five hundred
eighty eight dollars and eight
okay and what's your communication been
with them
um i called them i told them i wouldn't
have any money until
taxes came and then we just didn't have
it i mean we were
you know we were trying to take care of
stuff i paid off my car
you know so
so how much debt do you have outside of
this credit card
uh
well
this credit card which is 2214.73
is the other one and then um
and you're not making payments on that
one either
no
we just don't have it so what do you say
we don't have it you said you don't have
an income are you talking about your
husband no
yeah
none of us do really what's his income
he makes
um under 50 000 a year
okay is he willing to work
another job
well it's a little complicated
um i think
i think he is
but um he works
let me rephrase that space he needs to
get another job you guys don't feel the
sense of urgency that i'm feeling for
you which is you're on fire right now we
have to get these lawsuits out of our
life we have to get control and you've
got to pay the credit card
you've got to pay the bill and so
with this lawsuit i don't know what's
going to happen um you might be able to
settle but that would still mean you
need an amount in the bank that you are
able to pay because they're going to say
well
yeah you don't have an income but you
all have an income as a family and so
they can garnish his wages
they can do a lot of things and so you
need to get a little fire in your belly
to get this thing out of your life and
it's the same plan that everyone else
uses it's the debt snowball it's getting
your baby step one starter emergency
fund in place and starting to attack
this so i'm going to work with them to
go hey what amount are you willing to
settle for i don't want to take this to
the court what are you willing to do i
don't have much to my name i can
scrounge up a thousand dollars will you
take that and if they say yes you do it
let's not fight over this you went into
this debt we got to take some
responsibility here and stay somebody
tell you this right now your husband
needs to be working every night of the
week and then maybe he watches the kids
on the weekends and you're working we
are together going to go work and 2 000
to pay this office not that much money
if you both are working this is a great
economy to go make some money and
getting more income and then getting
disciplined is how you get out of this
mess no excuses this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
welcome back america you are listening
to the ramsay show i'm kid coleman
joined by george campbell this hour and
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage is brittany brittany
welcome hi how are you i'm excited to be
here all right so we're gonna do a
debt-free scream is that what's going on
here yes all right and where are you
from brittany i'm from smyrna georgia
smyrna georgia i know where smyrna
georgia is all right fantastic all right
let's get the details how much debt did
you pay off 32 000
okay and how long took me about 21
months 21 months what was your range of
income
um started around 35 and then by the
time everything was paid off about 46.
oh very nice what do you do i'm an
implementations manager for a tech
company nice that sounds very smart yes
like i feel i feel like britney has got
it together a lot of syllables in there
implementation manager yeah yeah i like
that sure nice so uh what was the debt
um a car loan credit cards and a little
bit of medical debt oh really okay
thank you george what was the car
um i had a mazda cx-5 uh-huh all right
how does that feel to have that one out
of the way it's huge it was actually the
last kind of thing that i did to pay off
my debt you know i thought that i was
going to be paying it off for another
year or two i didn't really want to let
go of that car that i still owed you
know money on but when i looked at the
numbers and i knew the used car market
right now is kind of crazy so
when we were just talking about it one
day i finally looked up and see to see
what it would appraise for and it when i
saw the numbers and knew that i could
get rid of my car but also get rid of my
car payment and also leave with a check
to pay off the rest of my debt it was
like a no-brainer easy decision
i love that so that was the acceleration
at the end yes to help you finish this
out yeah selling the car wow see i love
that a lot of people aren't willing to
do that and you did it and boy that
makes a big difference quickly so what
happened 21 months ago how did you how
did you get into this journey this
debt-free journey yeah so i'm
just like you guys always say i was a
financial peace baby so grew up in
church i always heard about dave ramsey
my parents are here they did financial
peace uh when i was younger and it's
funny i always remember like the first
class that they took um they made us
start ordering just water when we went
out to eat and i really hated that so
that's kind of how dave ramsey's been in
my mind over these years terrible
parenting
but just growing up i always knew about
it when i went to college i graduated
and moved home my parents so graciously
let me live at home without any you know
rent or anything so i didn't have any
bills
but also for first full-time income that
i wasn't used to having so really just
lived above my means and racked up all
the credit card debt that i could um i
also decided that it was time for me to
get my own car um instead of you know
having one without a car payment i
thought it was smart to you know really
be an adult and get my own car payment
so got myself car payment and then also
decided i wanted to move out on my own
so i got my own apartment of course had
to furnish the apartment all that
but just continued to still live above
my means and kind of got
over my head in credit card bills um and
then when my credit card started maxing
out i was like
i really got a problem
when i sat down and totaled it and i saw
it was
almost as much as i made in a year i
really knew that it was time to to do
something so i actually went to um
the bank and tried to get a loan like a
lot of people do
to consolidate and i didn't get accepted
for it and i just broke down crying
right there in the um
in the teller's cubicle and i felt
really bad but i was just like i don't i
don't know what to do i've lost hope um
and she gave me all the pamphlets and
everything that banks do you know credit
repair and all that but she she looked
at me and she was like
i don't have anything for this but we
went me and my husband went through um
dave ramsey's financial peace university
and it really changed our life changed
our marriage and i'm like yeah i know
about dave ramsey like you know
just like not something i wanted to do
but she didn't know but she was really
planting a seed and me and i didn't
realize that until later in life
actually a few months later i met my
boyfriend wit and we we
had the financial conversation about you
know
you can't really hide you know the
struggle that i was going through so we
we talked about it and he was like
i don't know if you've ever heard of
this guy um dave ramsey i was like yeah
okay god i see you like you bring a cue
boy in my life and of course i'm like
all in for it now you know i've heard it
for a million times as you dave ramsey
so
during quarantine when things were shut
down we watched all the
all the lessons together and then um
back in january we started it in person
class when things started kind of
opening up again so wow awesome so you
couldn't turn a corner without hearing
about this guy dave ramsey fine fine god
i'll do it yeah and it just worked yep
you got on the plane you decided to live
on less than you make get a hold of your
life
and here you are today on the debt free
stage yep you're a hero we're so proud
of you thank you that is awesome so what
was the hardest part in the journey for
you
um
i think just
for me it was most important to just
remember my why because there was times
where i was you know i did every side
hustle imaginable i had my normal
nine-to-five job and then i was out
doing door dash i walked a lot of dogs
did a lot of dog sitting so it was just
a lot of time that i didn't get to go
spend with my friends or do stuff that i
wanted to do and it was really hard but
in the back of my mind i knew it was a
temporary sacrifice to be able to live
you know comfortably for the rest of my
life and i just always had to go back to
my why
um when it did get hard there was a lot
of breakdowns and wit so gracefully
reminded me he's like just remember you
know this is only temporary you're gonna
you're gonna thank yourself for really
pushing through um yeah
wow
you had some cheerleaders in your corner
which is awesome i mean from the banker
to your boyfriend to your parents were
there any detractors
uh
no i don't think so okay i think she was
too busy to have any detractors i was
really busy you weren't really good you
hear the haters you were busy door
dashing right i was like i know you some
people think i'm crazy especially you
know now that i don't have i still don't
have a car i got rid of that in january
when i never got a new car not yet right
now i'm saving up cash for one so how
are you getting around just lyft and
getting rides from people no kidding
well i want to do a lot of walking
because where i live in smyrna it's you
know yeah good for you look at that see
that's enough
that right there bashes the myth that
you've got to have a car to function
right now some people do her life allows
her to do that but it can be possible oh
yeah and because you're budgeting for
the lift and all that stuff right and
i'm actually spending less than i did
with my car payment and with insurance
and with gas you know it came at the
perfect time in january when gas prices
i like that started skyrocketing so
you'll save up real fast now you don't
have a payment in the world nope wow so
i'm able to save a lot for uh
get a car in the next couple months so
what are you dreaming about now you're a
young lady your life's in front of you
you're debt-free how does that change
your perspective about the future it's
just awesome because now i feel like i
can actually save for my future and for
my family one day and my kids and i can
really give them the life that you know
they want so i'm excited to see do some
traveling
um we'll see everything's just it's so
much easier now you know like i said i
don't have any payments so i'm able to
save you know a lot of money and
start investing so i'm excited you and i
were talking about this during the
commercial break she's free oh yeah not
just free from debt she's free to make a
lot of different decisions
because she's not shackled by debt she's
got options now she's not backed into a
corner going well i got these payments
so what are you gonna do you decided to
take control instead of waiting for
someone else to fix your life exactly
and that's what this show is all about i
love that awesome just got to do it
fancy today what do you tell people
someone your age who's listening right
now watching what is the key to getting
out of debt
just know that there's hope and i think
when you're looking at any sort of goal
always look at what you want your life
to look like and for me it was just
remembering my why you know i can't wait
to live
debt free and be able to give back and
build my wealth and you know set myself
up for retirement one day but always
just looking
at what you want in life and then
working backwards and thankfully dave
gives you that plan the baby steps to
kind of get to that goal so it was easy
for me to follow that plan because i
knew at the end it would be so
worth it and that the temporary
sacrifice is like
is it's a lot shorter than you think
because i thought i was still going to
be paying for three four years but
really it only took me a little less
than two because i got that fire under
me um i was just hustling so i love that
yeah wow well brittany you inspire us
you're inspired a lot of young people by
telling your story so we thank you for
that we want to show our uh appreciation
to you by giving you two books one
dave's book total money makeover for you
to give to somebody else and kind of
pass that legacy on and then the next
step for you is baby steps millionaire
you're on your way you're going to be a
millionaire young lady and that is very
very exciting so we're going to give you
that book as well all right the time has
come britney are you ready i'm ready all
right she's going to do her debt free
scream it's brittany from smyrna georgia
she paid off 32 000 in 21 months making
35 000 all the way up to 46 000
brittany let's go let's hear your debt
free screen three two one i'm done free
[Music]
there it is
very nice
oh wow
for our listening audience i wish you
could just see her face and overcome
with the motion as she screams cathartic
free and she's crossed the finish line
proud mom and dad out there and don't
forget boyfriend of the year nominee wit
for all the support
the ramsay show continues right after
this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ramsay show continues
from our world headquarters in the
nashville area i'm kim coleman joined by
george campbell we're here for you this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two two five george it's hard to believe
we're less than a week away for uh from
our next live event in las vegas it is
our building wealth live event the event
is next thursday it's going to be really
really fun in vegas or surrounding areas
if you don't have your tickets yet make
sure to go and reserve your spot now
just a couple of clicks of a button will
put you on your way to doing better with
investments and savings we're going to
really talk about how to build real
wealth no matter where you are with
money today it is possible we're going
to tackle the latest get rich quick
trends dive deep into investing saving
and planning for retirement
and it's not complicated it's actually
simple we're giving you a clear path on
how to do all that and uh we know that
you'll win big dave ramsey rachel cruz
george campbell dr john deloney and i
are all together
uh at the event on the stage george is
going to wear a mini
uh elvis costume we did get that
approved i love that it's a mini one
well you're a small guy not a full-size
one i know that would look silly uh so
we're looking forward to that uh we're
not sure about the peanut butter banana
sandwiches uh we'll see about that so if
you're near las vegas in las vegas don't
miss out thursday may the 5th tickets
are just 25 each and you can get a four
pack of tickets for only 60 dollars
bring your friends it's gonna be great
ramsey solutions.com events ramsay
solutions dot com
slash
events see you there vegas
all right let's go back to the phones
martin is joining us now in cleveland
ohio home of the cleveland browns
oh yes martin how can we help
hey guys how you guys doing good what's
going on
all right so my wife and i are having a
a disagreement um kind of
so a short backstory we see you uh we
went to on vacation north carolina she's
been there her whole life and i i went
there one time with her and it's
obviously a gorgeous state uh right next
to tennessee
and uh
you know we talked about moving there at
one point i'm 25 years old she's 21. uh
we just got married less than a year ago
all right congrats all all of our family
is up here in cleveland like we have
eight sets of parents
everyone no one's in north carolina
um so i was thinking
we're on track to pay off our debts and
uh you know have a down payment here in
a couple years but i'm thinking you know
that's when we decide when do we play
down payment on a house near cleveland
near everyone um or should we move out
of state
the question is like my argument is
uh we have a big support system here
for you know when we have a kid
which i feel like that would be very
like useful you know uh babysitting and
whatnot but you know she really i really
want her to be happy and i really like
the state too
i'm a truck driver so driving not in the
winter would be great
because cleveland winters are pretty
brutal
okay so i i hear of the formation of a
question but i don't hear a specific
question so before we get to that did
you say you had eight sets of parents
did i hear that
yeah yeah so because every single one of
our parents got divorced and remarried
so we have eight pairs
oh okay gotcha all right needed clarity
on that that is a lot of babysitting
help i got to tell you as a guy with
three kids that's a real bonus i'm not
gonna let that one slide by all right so
what is the real question martin hit us
i guess the question is like what what
kind of questions would you ask
yourselves you know i can't even pick
out a drink at the gas station let alone
decide whether or not i should move your
different state well there's your first
problem paralyzed by indecision yeah so
you so here's the deal you need to
number one you need to
uh own the fact that you have a problem
making decisions and try to get behind
what's really about what's going on
there
um
but let's start with as a guy who's been
married almost 24 years let's start with
the all-important question what does
your wife want to do does she want to go
to north carolina or does she want to
stay in cleveland ohio
she thinks she wants to move to north
carolina okay so um what i would start
with is you guys need to go take a trip
to an area that she maybe maybe there's
three areas in north carolina i'm making
this up but i would take a nice little
weekend the two of you away and i would
go kind of just hang out see some
neighborhoods get an idea of what's
going on and let's get ourselves in that
environment and see how she really
responds and then you mr indecision guy
uh you need to be honest about what
you're afraid of right it's okay to just
say wow i'm worried about this and i'm
nervous about this george you uh tend to
be very neurotic what would you say that
is very true thank you for bringing that
up ken i'm working through it yeah uh
here's where i go with this i have
i don't live near my family anymore i
moved when i was 20. from boston and now
i'm in the south here my wife's family
they just moved down to florida so we're
not close to family we don't have kids
yet so similar to their situation
they're newlyweds so i'm not gonna make
a decision based on this alone
this is not a deal breaker for me to be
away from family i'm gonna we see our
families you know two three four times a
year yeah and it's not that big of a
deal so i wouldn't base it on free
babysitting let's stay in cleveland ohio
forever because of this
so
by the way the downside of all those
parents
it makes me think of a movie for
christmases there's a lot going on in
holiday time you know great movie but
yeah that's exhausting i'm exhausted
thinking about how you handle the
holidays martin which one excites you
more the idea of moving north carolina
as you guys talk about this do you start
to kind of your eyes light up a little
bit so
i i'm a very adventurous person i love
the idea of being by the ocean in north
carolina it's so gorgeous like i'm a
truck driver at night i hate winters in
cleveland truck driving it's a nightmare
but i'm also a very practical person and
i like to like lay out every little
number i can before i make a decision
and there's really no see see what you
just did there martin
you see you see what's going on george
asked you a point-blank question and
your heart let off
your heart answered yeah i want to be
near the beach i like the warm weather
uh i drive a truck i don't want to drive
in the winter you said all this earlier
so your heart is saying north carolina
but then you go then your head starts to
go
slow down skippy we have a lot of things
that could go wrong and your head starts
getting involved you can convince
yourself either way and truthfully
neither either one you'd have a fine
life
now the question is what can you do
without regret that's not going to keep
you up at night and the truth is you can
always go back home and visit the truth
is you can afford a babysitter when you
need to find someone to watch the kids
yeah and so if you look at the solutions
you go okay well if that was our deal
breaker i guess uh it's really not yeah
i i gotta tell you martin this is a good
old-fashioned pros and cons you and your
wife separate right uh and and she
writes her pros and cons for going uh to
north carolina and you do yours then you
guys meet in the middle of a nice little
candlelight dinner maybe uh compare
notes and then go to carolina one time
and you know i think it's going to be
obvious i think it's already obvious i'm
moving if i'm in their shoes just based
on what i know well i don't want to
knock anybody at cleveland ohio here
comes the hate mail but if it's between
cleveland ohio and charlotte north
carolina area it's not even up for vote
for me it's just me all right just me
thank you for that ken yeah i'm saying
well you gotta we're trying to head
trying to spread hate and dissension as
dave always says
oh
wow uh you know you make a very
interesting point though that's rare
sorry let's talk about the financial
questions yeah because we talked a lot
about those are more personal the
emotions and reasoning we talked a lot
about that what would you say to a young
couple on the financial side of things
what would they need to look at on a
move from one region to another i think
there's no urgency to this they're
newlyweds so i think it's okay to just
get to know each other let's pay off
this debt let's get an emergency fund in
place and let's reassess we're going to
be at a very different place emotionally
once we've been married for a year two
years the debts out of our life we've
got an emergency fund now we can be
clear-headed about every single decision
we're not worried about how we're gonna
pay for the move we're not as worried
about what's gonna happen with our our
jobs over there we can just do this with
a lot more clarity and so i'm
encouraging them to go hey pause what is
the urgency behind this do we need to
make this decision today or can we park
it and go hey let's focus on this debt
and let's circle back to this
conversation a year from now and see
where we're at yeah i like that because
the bottom line is that area or any
other area of the country still going to
be there and and so at that point we can
decide we want to clean up our financial
mess because again it just gives us more
options you know it changes where we
might be able to live in a certain area
uh the other thing that i don't think
people think through a lot is cost of
living oh yeah you know there is
cleveland to charlotte there could be a
jump there it might be yeah i don't know
uh but you got to look at all of that
and uh i just i don't i i i can't
overestimate
the importance of going and visiting
putting yourself in that place because
the fear that that holds a lot of people
up the most is the fear of the unknown
yeah and regret so go figure out what
you don't know go get an answer and now
we can make a decision based on real
information not a vacuum of fear and
doubt that's running around in our minds
a lot of wisdom there all right good
hour george
hey
this is your show folks it is the ramsey
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show it's
where we talk about your life your money
your work and your relationships i'm ken
coleman joined by george camel this hour
eight eight two five five two two five
is the phone number it's toll free
triple eight eight two five
five
two two five you ready to roll so ready
we're feeling good come on man calls are
on the board game on let's go rachel
joins us in bloomington indiana rachel
how can we help
hey i'm so glad to get you guys advice
on this
great um so my husband and i have been
saving um for our
home for like 15 years for a house in
the country
um and we found something that has a
barn and you know opportunity for
animals and things like that for our
kids which is what we want
um the problem is is we are we are
facing a lot of fears and concerns about
it and we don't know if these are
legitimate fears because it's not a good
financial decision or if this is just
like us stepping out of our comfort zone
because we really haven't had to do that
this the star in our marriage
so we need help deciphering
whether these are legitimate fears okay
great do you mind outlining very
specifically what the top fears are
um i think the top fear is that it will
be a financial burden instead of a
blessing for us
okay what else
um
we're worried that we'll regret it after
we do it
anything else we don't have enough
we won't have enough money to um
do things other than live in our home
like go on vacation
which leads me to believe george these
may be uh fears that protect not fears
that hold back we'll see break it down
see because fear is either here's what's
going on rachel i'm setting setting you
up because because these are financial
uh in in you and sharing these
and so here's what we know about fear
so fear can protect us right if we edge
up to the edge of a cliff right and we
start to feel a pang of fear fears
protecting us like slow down because you
could fall over to your impending death
right but sometimes fear can hold us
back right it's kind of the old the idea
of the elephant that's terrified of the
mouse you know
and and so we need to figure that out
george what do you think there with
those fears well my question is you've
been saving for 15 years how much money
do you have saved
um okay so
that we have um we're going to put 200
000 out of savings down on the home okay
and then we are expecting we have our
house paid off
and we're hoping to get 200
conservatively we will get 200 000 for
our home so we can put four hundred
thousand dollars down on on down on how
much
um it's 485 total
so you'd have an 85 000 mortgage
it's a mouse you're an elephant what's
your income i
listen okay so listen i stay at home my
husband works
um and he makes a net of 95 000 a year
okay and so the the big fear like we
understand we can't afford the house but
the big concern and the big fear is that
um the taxes are and insurance are going
to be pretty high like a lot higher than
what we're used to do you know that for
a fact do you know the exact number
uh we can we have a real good idea
okay are you talking property taxes
yes property taxes in bloomington
yep wow
i'm a little shocked by
we're left here in tennessee ken i'll
tell you that no property taxes are
pretty stiff here rachel when it comes
to mortgages let me just tell you our
parameters and i think this will give
you peace because it did for me uh when
we were paying off our house we tell
people to get a 15-year fixed-rate
mortgage the only one i'd ever tell you
to get where the the payment is no more
than a quarter of your take-home pay
that includes your principal interest
taxes insurance all in less than 25 of
take-home pay
and you're putting way more than 10 or
20 down so i'm not worried about that
so now let's look at the real numbers
you have an 85 000 mortgage we have
these high property taxes have you
crunched the numbers to see how much of
that of your take-home pay it's gonna
eat up
it's gonna take it's it's good i think
it's just under 25
okay okay but that so after the
after our house is completely paid off
with taxes and insurance we're still
gonna it's still gonna be one thousand
one hundred dollars just for taxes and
insurance okay that's okay i'm not as
worried about that so here's what i'm
seeing though if you look at those
numbers i want you to look at the facts
to give you some peace here and go okay
this is not 70 of our take-home pay
being eaten up by mortgage and taxes we
have 75 percent of our take-home pay to
still go accomplish all of our other
goals take care of our family go on
vacations we can still have a life
that's why we tell people to stick with
these conservative parameters because i
want you to still have a life
and that's what you're worried about are
we going to be able to do all these
other things if we have if we get into
this house and you told me it's been
your dream for 15 years
yes
and so to me there's some other fears
there other than financially you're not
broke you're not going to be broke no
you're going to pay this thing off uh
within what maybe two years
yeah i think it's just that's and that's
the thing we couldn't decipher whether
it was like this we just haven't had a
step out of our box you have is it just
so fear of stepping out of the box 100
rachel let me tell you what i heard
earlier you george walked you through
and you had you told him he said well
it's it's less than 25 percent he said
that's what we recommend it's very
conservative and your immediate response
was yeah but it's gonna be eleven
hundred dollars in taxes and that's a
new number for you and it seems
exorbitantly high because
based on your previous context it is
so i remember the first time my wife and
i bought a house it was 195 000 and i
thought i had i thought that i'd
mortgaged my future away and it was you
know i was making good but i mean i
never owned a house yeah so 195 000 is
like
you know what i mean and we were living
dave's principles my wife worked for
dave at the time i did not so i think
it's context
and george has just walked you through
and that you're okay and can i just also
say something i hope encourages you
what got you here is going to get you
there wherever there is you're going to
pay this house off you guys are going to
be baby steps millionaires true or false
i'd like to say true
no you will be you will be you're doing
it the right way you're going to pay off
that 80.
rachel
no no dad no okay yeah
and so
when you don't have any payments you
have freedom and so with that freedom
comes peace and so i want you to take a
look most people that call into the show
ken they have been wanting a house for
14 seconds they have no money to put
down and they do it anyways right
they've saved 200 000 over would you say
14 years 15 years 15 years it's time to
pull the trigger on this this is
i mean i don't even know how you've been
focused for 15 years i would have given
up
yes listen rachel that's what we're
doing we're bragging on you and your
husband
incredible discipline to have amassed
what you have amassed you guys are gonna
be great go get that place and it's
gonna be paid for in a few years and
then you'll have property taxes but
you'll still be unbelievably wealthy if
you just have property taxes and
insurance to pay for and as a home
warming gift george is going to send you
a baby llama so is that part of the plan
well i would send a baby camel before a
llama can you know i'm team campbell to
be on theme yeah i don't know who's
doing pr for llamas but they've done a
great job it's time for camels to step
up yeah well i got a 13 year old girl
and any parent or 13 year old girl gets
that i don't know where these animals
came from with their popularity but it
is what a diatribe we just went huh left
turn there well adhd is a real thing
george and the next medication point is
uh later this hour so hey don't move
more of the ramsey show coming right up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america you are listening
to the ramsay show thrilled to have you
with us
helping you win with your money winning
your work winning your relationships i'm
ken coleman joined by george campbell
the phone number is free to call in for
some breakthrough triple eight eight two
five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's go to
minneapolis where savvy joins us on the
line savvy how can we help
hi guys thank you so much for taking my
call of course what's happening today
all right let me give you some
background information okay so in two
weeks i'm graduating with my undergrad
degree nice
yes and i'm also a part of an
accelerated master's program through
this school that i'm about a quarter way
through my master's in counseling
so
then in june i'm getting married
and
we combined we'll have around 100k in
student loan debt
um
but i also got a job on monday and my
fiance is currently working he makes
about 53k a year and i'll be making
around 50k a year so total we'll have
around 103 000 per year as our salary
and we're completely down to start the
baby steps
but
we want to cash flow my master's so that
we don't have any more student loan debt
and
we are just wondering if
it would be wise to
treat the master's fund as
a baby step before we start the baby
steps save up all the cash in around six
or seven months to just fully fund that
and how much
okay how much it would be the what
what's left in the master's fund to be
able to pay that
um it would be around so we would have
about 20k total my grandparents gifts
every grandchild during college
graduation nine grand to use for
whatever so we're going to put that
towards the masters as well so we have
around 11 or
yeah 11 or 12. so you'd have to come up
with 11
to uh
to cash flow your way through
yeah um
i'm not suggesting you do this i'm just
asking if you were to press pause
on the master's degree because you're
already employed i'm assuming are you
employed in the area that you want to be
in with this masters in counseling or is
it completely separate
so my master's is online
and i my job i begin after married and
it is where my fiance is living in
colorado right now right but is it is it
in the field of counseling your job
um no it's an hr okay so it's totally
unrelated
um
and you do it all online
so
pausing is not something you're
interested in doing because it's gonna
take you a while
uh i can see that to pay off the you
know the 103 even with that great income
yeah um yeah well george i mean i
absolutely believe we she can cash flow
your thoughts on this yeah i mean we
want to avoid debt no more at all costs
and so if that means cash flowing while
we pay minimum payments on the rest of
our debt that's okay that's you're
investing in savvy right now and we'll
get to that debt when you graduate and
you've got that new job we're gonna
start attacking this debt with a
vengeance so i'm okay with that i love
the idea of you cash flowing this 11.
the question is how fast can we do it
and can we accelerate that even faster
yes are you going to be able to save 11
in time before the master's program
starts
so i'm going so i'm in the fall i'll be
enrolling in my next classes and we're
going to use the nine grand um each
semester is around five grand so we're
gonna use five of the nine to pay for
that continue saving for the next
semester we should be able to get that
much money by then and then
something i forgot to mention is with my
job that i just got is they will
reimburse you five grand a year for
educational reimbursement wow
i can also i could
really
get the majority of the remainder paid
for by my job but they only pay like in
january and i'd be enrolling in
august
or whatever so we'd have to pay forward
before that so
the nine grand would cover what how much
which months
um the nine grand would cover the fall
semester
and then um a little over half of the
next semester after that and then i
would
get reimbursed by my work that
is well that brings your cost down to
what six grand
yep something like that so now the
question is how quickly can i save up
six grand
making 50k a year
yeah plus side hustles i mean selling
stuff
uh every everything because what george
is leading you to here is is that the
quicker we can fund the masters the
quicker we start on the baby steps
exactly so if you've got that money set
aside for the masters you know it's
going to be paid for now we can start
attacking the debt while we're still in
the master's program
yeah and how how quickly is this masters
gonna happen
um so we'll have around three grand take
home each month after paying all of our
bills um
so it should be around two months if we
were really grinding with like the baby
step mindset towards saving up for the
master's money okay um
yes but i think the question george is
asking is how long before you finish the
master the accelerator program yeah when
is this going to be
um so i'd have around two and a half
years left okay
all right and what do you want to do
with that master's
so i will be in the lpc after i pass my
exam after that master's so i just want
to be a mental health counselor in
um really any setting i'm down to try um
awesome yeah so i'm looking forward to
that too yeah well thank you so much for
the call yeah absolutely it sounds like
this thing's uh you've got the plan
let's just stay on the course yeah avoid
debt and we'll get this debt knocked out
yeah i love the intensity advice let's
get on those baby steps fast um and she
does very little to fund they can do
this oh yeah multiple jobs i mean this
is good after it's stuff let's go to
barry in sacramento california barry how
can we help
hey guys thank you for having me on sure
um i've got a life
changing opportunity coming up i've got
settlement money that i never expected
coming in and i
have no idea what to do with it i've
seen a lot of money go with a lot of
zeros
behind it and turn quickly into zeros in
front of that so i
am
new i just want to know what you guys
might have uh an opinion on on what i
should do with this money what kind of
settlement was this
um this is a big settlement i lost
everything that i've ever owned and this
is kind of paying me back for that hmm
so not health related
no
okay
how much how much is the money how much
money you get i
and close to 200
210 after taxes and everything okay uh
what are you doing for work right now
uh right now i'm putting myself through
a two-year program at a community
college i'm a single dad and i'm working
part-time
minimum wage okay do you have any debt
uh it's just eight thousand on my car
okay and no credit card debt
how much money do you have to your name
and savings
uh
about
about three months worth of
living
okay like three lanes four grand well
when is the settlement coming through
when does this hit your bank account
well it comes in steps and i'll be
getting my first soon at around 90
and then over the next few years broken
into two more payments okay
well the fact that you called in makes
me think that you want to make sure you
use this money wisely and if you're not
careful this this money could disappear
with a blink and you alluded to that
earlier
yes so if i'm you when this check clears
that first one i'm paying off the debt
and i'm staying out of debt we're never
touching debt again and you can leave
that money in there in savings i might
bump that up to six months for you being
a single dad and uh we got to get you
away from this minimum wage job i think
you can do better in this market right
now even while you're going to community
college and ken's got a lot of resources
on his website to help you in that arena
but we have got to make sure we use this
money wisely beyond that
if you don't have a home right now that
might be a down payment fund if you
could pay cash for something that's even
better but you're in sacramento so
that's a pipe dream but maybe eventually
this becomes a down payment for a house
and uh we invest some of this and we
start to really make a plan for what
life looks like as a single dad taking
care of our kids and leaving legacy yeah
barry uh you don't need to live off of
any of this do exactly what george said
the baby steps hang on we're gonna give
you a couple of resources one total
money makeover
two i'm going to give you the
get clear career assessment i want you
to take a 20 minute assessment really
give you some direction into what could
be some great work for you good money
and a whole lot of meaning as well so
hang on we'll give you both of those
resources because i want you making
really good money
now that you've got a good head start
with this settlement thank you so much
for the call this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
so
[Music]
the ramsay show continues thrilled to
have you america i'm ken coleman joined
by george campbell
you need to find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more if you use the
promo code ramsey you get the best deal
today's question comes from bianna in
ohio briana says my husband and i are
debt free except for our 500 000
mortgage my husband earns 120 000 a year
and i am a stay-at-home mom my question
is do i go back to school for nursing
and hopes to make a better living and to
help contribute doing so would create
school debt of fifty thousand dollars we
would pay it off in two years then we
would be able to contribute to
retirement and pay off our mortgage or
do i just go back to the workforce at
entry level making decent money but
never really being able to further my
career since i do not have an education
um
very complex question well but we've got
some logic that's kind of running into
itself yeah so the question brianna is
is do i go back to work because i want
to help make more money okay for for
contributing is the word you used
but
getting 50 000 in debt paying for two
years on that fifty thousand dollars in
debt
to help contribute is backwards so let's
go to option two because it's option two
but you've got a false narrative in
option two option two is or do i just go
back to the workforce at entry level
making decent money but never really
being able to further my career so the
idea of you going in back to work does
not have to be entry level per se
you don't know that
but if you were to go in entry level the
very definition of entry level is i'm
just on the bottom rung which means
there's opportunity to climb and you can
do that take project management work
right we've gotta you know if you're
organized and you love details and i
have no idea if she is or not but you
begin to go i could be an office manager
you know i could do some basic
accounting if i'm good with numbers you
know a lot of jobs you can get in and
make really good hourly uh money and
it's not minimum wage and there's an
opportunity for you to grow because
here's what's going to happen
as you get into that you can save money
brianna
towards the nursing degree if nursing is
something you want to do so go get the
day job if nursing is the dream job
let's go get a day job let's contribute
to paying off the mortgage or whatever
and as you're doing so you save some
towards nursing and eventually you fund
the nursing degree but it's not going
into debt um that's not gonna help
contribute anything other than stress
and frustration yeah a few things i'll
add to that i'm seeing
a 500 000 mortgage and 120 120 grand a
year my guess is this mortgage is eating
up a large percentage of their income i
think they may have too much house yeah
i agree and so you might need to look
into do we need to get a different
housing situation in order to cash flow
my education if that's the path you
decide to go the other piece i want to
hit on here ken is
to help contribute as if she's not
contributing
at home by being a stay-at-home mom
there's immense value there absolutely
and so i don't want you to i think
what's happening here she's feeling like
well i'm not contributing to this family
so i need to go out there and do work
yeah that's not the case yeah and so if
if he's making 120 grand we can figure
out a way to make this money work for us
but it's gonna entail getting out of
debt staying out of debt and maybe
looking at if we have we bid off more
than we can chew with this mortgage but
either way we're not going into debt for
education and uh really decide if
nursing is really the path or if there's
something else but to decide well
there's either entry level or nursing
those are the only two options false
narrative that's not true wow appreciate
the question let's go back to the phones
valdosta georgia is where gregory joins
us gregory how can we help
hey um
so i'm 19 and i'm just like starting my
life out because i've been in community
college for like a year now
and i'm gonna make a big move
and i'm trying to decide
on how would y'all start off in my
position
what's the big move
well i'm moving to another town because
right now i'm living with my own family
and i'm gonna move in
with my other family so i'll get on my
feet
in a better town and a better
environment okay
uh why is it a better town better
environment describe that
um
i've seen i've seen since like
it's a bigger town like i think the cost
of living
is a little higher right but um
also is like money what it's a good
money flow more more professional
options
um
right now i'm studying for automotive
technician
and i'm on a one-year diploma right now
looking to get certified okay
so i was wondering
should i like i'm just kind of debating
because i'm like
because right now i'm in the academic
portion of college
and i didn't want to stress myself out
so i didn't get a job
so i've been home
okay so you're okay so you're one year
in a community college
um and and so is is what you're doing in
the community college is that getting
you that mechanical
certification or however you would
phrase that
yeah yeah it's getting my certification
in that
only reason i'm getting certified
because i can go out there and just work
on cars on the street and stuff and yeah
that was nice that's my question so
let's just press pause on the community
college for a second uh you know your
way around an engine i'm guessing yes
yes sir
what would keep you uh from getting a
job with a local mechanic in this new
town you're moving to
um
i just wanted to be certified so i'll
have like a bigger gain i understand
that but that's not the question i asked
what would keep you from getting hired
even if it's entry-level mechanic in
this new town anything
not really meaning you got the chops you
could go in an interview if you had an
interview
you feel like you got the chops the
ability to go in and do basic mechanic
work regardless of the certification
that's what i'm asking do you believe
that's true
yes sir yeah interesting
well how soon are you making the move to
the town the new town
well
the
next semester because i can transfer
colleges because they have the same
campus on in the other town
so um
that starts may the 16th
so it's pretty soon
okay
i'm just now finishing
no no you're good so in may you're gonna
move and uh how much left of the
uh community college work to get the
certification to be able to get paid
more as a mechanic how much is that of
of that is left uh right now with the
academics i only have an essay
then
may the 16th i start the afternoon
classes for my mechanics so what i was
going to do was going to pick up a job
yeah um
and just go in the afternoon to those
classes right so i'm trying to figure
out
what would you do
i'm sorry no i'm just gonna
what would you do
in my position like trying to
trying to save money because i've been
working ever since i was 16. i worked at
a peanut mill and i used to make like
bring home maybe 800
a week seasonally
and um i used to just help my parents
with bills because
i i just feel like i just felt at that
time i had to
well so what's your question gregory it
sounds like we make this move we get a
part-time job we start the new semester
at the new community college we cashflow
the whole thing and life's great
where what's holding you back yeah i get
a job i don't think this is that intense
that that community college go go get
some part-time work and then get done
with the certification as soon as
possible and get hired as a mechanic you
enjoy the work you're good at the work
let's go
yes sir now george tell him how to save
money once he's making full-time money
well do you have any debt gregory
currently
no i don't have any debt i'm perfectly
clean clean slate okay i don't
have any money in savings
oh no sir okay so you have no money to
your name except whatever is in your
checking account
i don't even have a checking account
you don't have a bank he's living with
family and going to school
but how old are you you're 19 you don't
have a bank account we need to fix that
today i'm going down to a local credit
union your local bank and open an
account today
i mean where's your paycheck going are
you cashing it at
walmart we got to figure that piece out
so i'm getting banked because that's
going to help you get on your feet get a
savings account and start to make some
wise financial moves stay out of debt
and you'll be okay you're a sharp dude
you'll make some good money being a
mechanic in the trades we love that yeah
if we ain't working we can't save so
part-time job first paycheck that bank
account set up and uh hang on the line
let's uh let's give you total money
makeover it's going to see how to stay
debt free how to save how to build well
hang on the line
this is the randy show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america you are joining the
conversation here on the ramsey show i'm
ken coleman joined by my colleague
george campbell
uh
so george we're talking about life we're
talking about money we're talking about
work relationships and
saw a headline cnbc article
college graduates are overestimating the
salaries they'll start at by as much as
50
000
all right so give you some back story on
this as hiring demands
have continued to increase coming out of
the pandemic very hot job market right
more jobs available than there are
people who are unemployed so it's just
driven up salaries and this is part of
the inflation game right what people do
you understand about inflation is one of
the inflationary measures that we tend
to not think about is when when
paying a starting
uh hourly rate of 17 an hour well
they're going to pass that on to the
consumer uh in the form of the cost of
your lupa or luffa or whatever those
things are thank you for remembering ken
absolutely and uh so uh what we're
seeing now is uh obviously average
starting salaries even for college
graduates is sneaking up the class of
2022 george is projected to make
uh to be a starting salary is projected
to be more than fifty thousand dollars
however
this is where the reality check needs to
come in
that same group of students 2022 grads
are expecting to earn twice that amount
in their first job and they're expect to
make six figures job
so uh
we've got a real disconnect there
uh undergraduate students across all
majors and institutions overestimated
their starting salaries by 88 percent
this is a study from the real estate
witch
uh which needs a branding class wow
that's unfortunate oh my goodness and 10
years into their careers these students
anticipate making more than 200 000 so
well over the average mid-career salary
of 132 000.
wow so george where do you think that's
coming from you you're tied into that
the youngsters i think youngsters they
have a
pretty high risk tolerance and so
they're looking at college going well
yeah if i go to college you
automatically get a high paying job at
the end of it as soon as you walk the
stage they just come clamoring to give
you a job with six figures and that's
not the case and i'll tell you that be i
say that because i sat down with a bunch
of high schoolers as we were filming our
personal foundations and finance
curriculum personal finance curriculum
and as i interviewed these students i
went so what do you want to do
what kind of job where you want to go to
school how much is going to cost how
much do you think you're going to make
some of them thought it was an
interrogation they ran away in tears
after we were done wow no one has asked
them these questions ken including their
parents they're not having these
conversations the teachers that's where
these crazy numbers are and so it's all
in their mind of just going well a
hundred thousand dollars about what mom
and dad make so that's what i'm gonna
make when i graduate college and there
was such a disconnect
they went well this is how much i'm
going to get paid as a
physical therapist whatever the job was
it was always inflated now they may get
there over time but year one you're not
going to be making six figures in most
jobs no listen
this information right here folks is why
it's vitally important for
high schools public private and colleges
to teach financial literacy you know i
mean i mean it's it's so important i'll
tell you what it leads to because they
have no idea it leads to the student
loan crisis we're seeing because
students go well ken i'm happy to take
on a hundred thousand dollars because
i'll be able to pay it off easily that's
always the case and what happens they
have 150 000 in student loans and
they're making 42 000 a year and then
they feel like they were lied to and
they demand student loan forgiveness
because this is a scam oh yeah when they
really just didn't do their due
diligence they didn't do their research
they didn't have the right conversations
and it's heartbreaking i don't want this
for any student it really is because
here's what here's where the perfect
storm collides
they've created this mythical salary in
this this mythical financial
journey that they're going to be on and
then that doesn't happen and then
they've grown up getting a trophy just
for showing up right you sports and it's
just like so then all of a sudden the
reality hits them and it's no joke
it's not funny it's it's it's
disheartening and disillusioning when
they come out and they feel like
i went and did all this time i got all
this debt i could barely afford the debt
payment and i was supposed to have this
life you talk about rocking somebody's
world while the brains are still
developing well an 18 year old has no
idea what it's like to pay bills to pay
insurance no um and so they walk into
their adult life going hold on i have to
make a car payment and my student loan
payment and my credit card payment and
they can't breathe so you've got to have
a reality check here come on wake up
folks wake up all right ashley is
joining us now in chicago illinois
ashley how can we help
oh my word hi guys thanks for taking my
call you bet ashley she's so sure about
you what's happening
that's awesome um george you're my
favorite by the way anyway
hold on a second hold on james can i
take this segment off ashley give me a
second i have to take the dagger out of
ken's heart
it's okay george hannah i'm gonna take a
smoke break go ahead
ashley how can we help today
all right so in short my mother-in-law
is trying to buy my husband and i a 500
000 house whoa and
yeah
and um he's an only child works in the
family business is planning to take over
and um we've also been living rent-free
in one of their properties uh the last
three years since we've got married so
we've never really had to worry about
you know the normal bills all of that
and so i came from a different
background i'm kind of feeling like
we're being taken care of which is a
good and a bad thing um but i also don't
feel like we're adults he thinks we
should be taking kind of taking
advantage of this and looking at it as
you know the lord is blessing us with
so much um and she wants to buy us this
house because we had our first daughter
four months ago
um
congratulations
yeah that's awesome thank you is she
paying cash for this house on your
behalf is she just gifting you a paid
for 500 000 house
yes exactly all cash
whoa
so i kind of feel like we're cheating
our way through the baby stuff but i
also feel like if we said no to this i i
think i'm looking for permission
um i'm not really sure i well george is
your favorite so george my family
wow you've lost ken that
he's done with you ashley no this is
fascinating no this is a wild scenario i
mean in this case i don't want you to
feel like you're cheating now i don't
want her you know coddling you guys
forever and giving you an allowance
you're grown adults and so i think what
you're wanting is that sense of
independence and agency and going hey i
pay my own bills i'm a grown woman i'm a
mom which by the way you will exactly
which you will and so i'm looking at
this as they they've left a legacy they
want to bless you with this and so now
if she said hey i'm going to take out a
mortgage in your name and you pay the
bills i'm going
now i do want to know if there's any is
there any agenda here is she saying hey
i'm hands off i don't get to tell you
how to live your life financially i just
want to bless you with this is there any
strings attached
not that i know of um in the past
they've definitely been the more um
you know want to know what's going on in
our life our house was next door to them
before and they want to kind of be in
our business but it's gotten a lot
better the past year
um this house is about 20 minutes
farther from them from where we are now
so we do like that idea that's healthy
but um
the fact that my husband is an only
child
has taken longer to have they spoiled
him
oh yes it sounds like he's had it pretty
good
now we're starting to get she knows it
yeah
well is she still folding his laundry i
mean what level of you know coddling is
happening here oh very
so he's very independent at home um
he cooks for me so i love it
i just wanted to make sure because
sometimes you kind of have those
helicopter parents that can't let go of
their little boy and it's a grown man
now and he's a dad and we have to
separate and so if i'm you i'm taking
this deal i mean this is the deal of a
century and it's gonna catapult you into
baby step seven and the best thing you
can do is take advantage of this by
staying debt-free building unbelievable
wealth leaving a legacy for your kids
and maybe doing the same for them one
day i don't know what that looks like
for you guys but i'm taking this deal
and i think you you may have to grapple
with the emotions of this being handed
to you and feeling like wow was such
privilege but yeah this is what legacy
looks like
and so i'm gonna take that as a blessing
and make sure there's no strings
attached and say hey mom you know
in-laws love you guys but
there's no say over what you know you
tell us to do with our money in our life
but we so appreciate you guys this is
the biggest blessing of our life
any advice on how to explain this to
my family who's in a completely opposite
situation
are they going to
i don't think they're going to be upset
i think they're going to wonder how how
are we doing this
[Music]
well you know you're not taking a poll
and so you tell them as news you're not
asking for an opinion here and you move
on with your life you say mom dad i love
you guys we've been blessed with this
and i wanted to let you guys know
and that's it yeah really great congrats
on the little one congrats on this
unbelievable gift it is a blessing i
agree with your husband take it hey uh
george good stuff good hour thanks for
hanging out i think james and the entire
team
behind the glass and most importantly
want to thank you america this is your
show it is the ramsay show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show it's
where we talk about your life your money
your work and your relationships triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the toll free number to jump in
i'm ken coleman he's george campbell and
we are here for you this hour thrilled
that you've joined us triple eight eight
two five
five
two two five george you're ready to go
you ready to help some people always
ready always a good day when it's with
ken coleman oh well i appreciate that i
appreciate that john joins us next in st
louis missouri john how can we help
hey how's it going guys good to be
talking to you good to talk to you
so listen i got a new job recently that
i'm really excited about moving to a new
state a huge pay bump and i was going
over the health care plan that they
offer
they offer a core plan and a high
deductible plan with the hsa which is a
plan i currently have at my old company
but the difference is here this company
they fully cover the premiums on both
plans which means you know nothing would
come out of my paycheck every month
awesome so i'm you know i'm relatively
healthy you know i'm kind of wondering
if i should go with the core the hsa
since the premiums are covered uh the
flip side of that is that the
company actually contributes about
fourteen hundred dollars a year towards
the hsa so that's also another thing to
consider but i'm just kind of wondering
i will be the better option in my case
so
you're saying do both plans have an hsa
so there's a core plan
there's the core plan that's like normal
like the like a normal healthcare plan
and then there's the high deductible
plan with the hsa i like that option
yeah so what was keeping you from just
sticking with that
yeah i was just wondering because since
they cover the premiums on both plans
100
would it be better to go with a plan
that has a lower deductible well it
sounds like the the incentive to go with
the high deductible plan is the extra
1400 bucks a year they're thrown into
your hsa
right
okay that's what i was kind of thinking
too but i was kind of wondering if that
would be the smarter choice yeah i mean
if you're saying you're a healthy guy
that's still going to be my choice and
the hsa has some amazing triple tax
advantages and you can also start
investing in your hsa once you hit the
threshold in that
account okay perfect yeah i already have
the hsa my current company and uh you
know i really like it there i was just
wondering since i've never had a company
that pays
a hundred percent of the premium so
that's kind of a really cool great
benefit
i love that but i'm still going with the
high deductible plan and the hsa that's
going to be your best bet you can cover
all your health care expenses through
that hsa begin investing in that it can
actually be a cool tool in retirement at
that point so that's what i'm going with
man congrats it's awesome love it
appreciate the call john you're on your
way let's go to jt who joins us in
houston texas jt how can we help
well ken george very nice to hear from
y'all and really appreciate what all you
all do
thank you sir how can we help
well sir i am
starting to look at starting a family
with my wife
and
the
car buying industry right now in texas
has just been absolutely hot
five-year-old explorers are going for
the same as msrp
when they were selling brand new and new
cars right now have 10 to 20 000
on top of them
if i'm looking for a
paid in cash baby hauler what exactly am
i looking for what do you recommend all
right well
jt you said you're looking to start a
family so that means is is is your wife
pregnant or are we just getting excited
about the trying process
birth control is coming out next week
okay and okay that's enough information
for us yeah yeah we didn't need any more
than that but that does help us so we
don't need a baby hauler right now
what's the urgency
i'm the nerd of the relationship she's
the free spirit okay what are your two
i'm assuming you guys have two cars is
that true
yes sir okay what are you driving
i have a 2020 volkswagen passat that i
just paid off uh yesterday hey
congratulations how about that all right
what is she driving
she has a 2001 f-150 all right here's
the great news about both of those cars
all right if you have one baby and it is
possible to have twins and triplets i
don't want to freak you out
but it's possible
all right but if it's just here a little
bit i know dude relax take a deep breath
get a get a brown paper back jt keep it
close by here's the thing man it's a
good chance it's just going to be one
and both of those cars fit one car seat
all right i know you can look look at me
and listen to me and go ken's no baby
expert and you'd be right but i do have
three kids and they were all babies and
i know that one car seat will fit in
both of those cars here's the point i'm
making we've got time we've got some
time we need to relax you don't need a
baby hauler in fact you already have two
baby haulers you don't have eight kids
you don't need to go buy an astro van i
mean what's i don't i think there's more
behind this i think you're are you
nervous about having a kid
of course he is everybody that wasn't
even understated that would be an
understatement that's really the
underlying problem it's not really a
financial question it's not do i need a
car now he's just going oh gosh oh gosh
how is life going to be different once i
have a kid what does this mean for us
and i think those are fair questions to
ask but take a deep breath it's going to
be okay do you so do you have any debt
right now jt
you told me just paid off the car
anything else
only thing we have well actually that's
a story out of itself we sold my wife's
2019 rav4 for two grand more than we
bought it two years ago and then use the
10 grand in positive equity to pay off
my car right and a good portion of
credit card debt so all that's left is
about
12 000 in credit card debt and we're
done which is going to be in the next
three to four months fantastic okay so
that's i think what's going to give you
the piece is we're going to pay off all
of our credit card debt then we can have
a fully funded emergency fund and start
saving up for a car if necessary i truly
don't think you need one in the next few
years
i think unless you have multiple kids i
mean a baby fits in a passat i never
thought i'd have to say that on air but
it's true yeah now jt i don't want you
to faint with this but if you have twins
you can still put two kids and two car
seats in a passat and an f-150 if it's
got a car
so you'll be okay until you actually
feel the pinch we go oh this car's too
tight we can't get it's just too much
and over that by then you're gonna be
able to save up and pay cash for a
bigger car if you need if you need the
minivan if you need the baby hauler as
you called it you'll be able to do that
with cash i would not worry about the
car market just buy the car that you can
afford
jt what got you to this point of being
close to being debt-free is gonna keep
you out of debt it's gonna allow you to
save up for any car that you need i
promise
and it's now let me just speak
practically to this if for some reason
you know you're thinking well my passat
or her f-150 isn't gonna do it i'm in
the car market right now for my wife
number one and number two for a teenager
who's about to be driving i'm looking at
cars all the time
uh if we're just calling it a baby
hauler there are plenty plenty of good
deals that you will be able to afford
and pay cash
that are serviceable and they may not be
they won't be brand new and they may not
be a couple years old but they will get
baby and mama and daddy from point a to
point b so appreciate the call jt and
listen um
i didn't know what i was doing when our
kids were born i still don't know what
i'm doing as a dad of teenagers it's
okay you're gonna be okay man you're a
good dude you're responsible and it's
going to be all right
and if you need car buying advice i mean
if you're looking at suvs and minivans
later on
toyota and honda are solid solid
vehicles uh i understand what our car is
what was that other brand toyota okay
they always make fun of me i say toyota
instead of toyota whatever you said
america was going i've never heard of
that car brand george and we trust you
america's tell me your problems ken than
how i pronounce toyota oh no it's not a
problem i just needed to clarify it you
did good
hang in there george it's all good we'll
get there you're the man hey don't move
more of your calls coming right up this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america you are listening
to the ramsey show a conversation about
your life your money your work your
relationships george campbell
and i can coleman join you to take your
questions triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eigh eight two
five
five two two five let's go to new york
city new york mike is there mike how can
we
help hey guys thanks for taking my call
i love the show thank you sir how can we
help you
uh so i graduated school in 2020 with
about 47 000 in student loan debt
and over the past 18 months i've been
paying that down even though it's been
in forbearance
with everything going on in the news
recently and talks with biden writing
off 10k
of student loans it just so happens that
i'm
at about 10 000 left um so i'm just kind
of
wondering should i
just keep paying it down or
potentially leave free money from the
government on the table
i'm sorry i'm not laughing at you i'm
laughing at that statement free money
from the government uh a thing that
doesn't exist actually it's always
coming back to you one way or the other
and um i i could be wrong on this and
i'm hoping i'm wrong
um
but uh
i don't see it happening i think it's a
campaign year midterm elections are
coming up
and i think this is something that uh
gets dangled out there
because it is uh
it's a winning talking point in that a
lot of people have student loans are
going oh that would be great it'd be
great it'd be great um but i just do not
expect it to happen because quite
frankly student loans are big money
business for the government george yeah
i'm i'm 100 with you ken as i was
laughing at the uh the idea of well in
the news there's been talks
oh a politician talking look at that
that's progress
and so i'm not banking on that and like
ken's saying what's happening here is
approval ratings are low midterms are
coming up we got to make them look good
to get rea so what's happening here is
they dangle the carrot to make people
vote and then they keep kicking the can
down the road and as we've seen the
student loan forgiveness stats are
abysmal
one or two percent of the people that
applied have been forgiven and you've
already done the hard work mike to get
down to ten thousand dollars from 47. so
how many more months is going to take
for you to pay off
uh it should be done in in august
i'll tell you this much by august there
will not it will not have happened
i'm happy to be wrong like ken said and
uh you will not look back with regret
when you're debt free and you don't have
a payment in the world you know just be
happy for those that got their 10 000
paid off if it even ever happens but i'm
not holding my breath
and mike listen you're a good dude i
mean you're a high character guy that's
why you've already gone after it you
know you've already been paying it down
even though they were in forbearance and
smart listen
you took out the loan does not make you
evil does not make you bad you're not a
criminal you're not a person of low
character but you signed up for that you
took it out and paying it back and i
just think that you know we've we've got
to remember this folks that you know you
know
at the end of the day i understand why
emotionally if you've been under the
weight of these loans that you're
holding out for it but i wouldn't hold
out for it yeah well people feel like
they've been lied to when it comes to
the entire student loan crisis and
college and the promises at the end of
the day at what point do we go well we
should extend this to credit card debt
and all kinds of debt and the truth is
you signed up for the debt you got to
pay it back that's just how it works you
don't want to do that don't go into debt
no
so uh way to go mike keep paying it off
call us back when you're dead free we
would love to celebrate with you august
is going to be here before you know it
mike really proud of you man keep on
going and it's it's going to be a
challenge that you look at on the other
side of this thing of being free of that
student loan debt you're gonna look back
and it's gonna it's gonna really build
character it's gonna teach you a lot
it's it's gonna remind you later on in
life where you have another challenge
that you can do it so
there's nothing but positives by paying
this off
uh houston texas is where we go next
marianne is on the line marianne how can
we help
hi my name is miriam and i am calling
another student debt question
uh
basically i have a bachelor's degree um
in a degree that i haven't used i
finished it like over 10 years ago maybe
13 years ago now
it was a communications degree and then
i became a then i was a stay-at-home mom
for a while
and
i our home is paid off
um so we don't have debt um
but
there have been a couple bumps along the
way as happens in some people's lives
anyway long story short i'm here and
we just had a baby about eight months
ago
but i i have been thinking about going
back to school i had been working as a
teacher i mean i was stay-at-home but
then i went back to like work as a
teacher part-time at the preschool where
my daughter was at and then i went to
doing that full time
anyway
um i had been taking pre-requisite
classes in school saying speak directly
in your phone marianne it sounds like we
got some wind or something there oh sure
so i have been taking the prerequisite
classes just one at a time you know
while i was working
um
and i finished them i got into a state
school
so the price is right um we saved up the
money we do have the money to pay for
the school outright but i'm like i did
apply for as you know for the
scholarships they had available and i
got you know like four thousand dollars
in scholarships which i was really proud
of and i was like that's great you know
that'll help
um
we have about maybe 40 000 saved my
husband makes about 40 000 a year
um
and
i just i mean there is like they do have
this unsubsidized or they have a
subsidized loan
it's just fifty five hundred dollars hey
marianne let me ask you a question um
what are you getting a degree in i
didn't catch that what are we why are we
going back to getting oh
i i'm getting a degree in nursing i'm
getting um it's an accelerated 15-month
program for nursing school that way
i just
wanted to be able to increase my income
from being
you know a preschool teacher and i know
i probably could do other things but do
you want to be a nurse
or is this just a i mean well let me let
me ask it differently do you want to be
a nurse because you are a caregiver and
you love the idea of that interaction or
do you want to be a nurse because
benefits are great and the money's much
better than a preschool teacher
i'd say it's a combination of both like
i for a long time when after i had my
first kid and even a little bit before
that i was really interested in like
holistic and kind of like healing and
preventative medicine and that kind of
care so as far as being a caregiver
i have that part down
and so how much money would you have to
i'm sorry to interrupt how much money
are you going to have to um
borrow
to pay for this nursing degree because
you don't have the cash
we do have the cash in our savings so
why are you considering a student loan
if you have the cash to pay for it yeah
that's where i'm at i love that voice
sorry well i was just i just thought
like maybe it would be like free money
which you know you guys are the wrong
people what is free money i'm so
confused since when is a student loan
free money
well because there's no interest being
charged on it while i'm in school and
the interest only accrues until six
months after so i figured like hold on
you just told me you have a paid for
house did you guys get out of debt at
some point
sorry
yeah i i do have paid for his house okay
never mind i'll hang up i'm embarrassed
i'm not trying to embarrass you i'm
trying to show you i'm trying to show
you the logic of you guys work so hard
to get out of debt so that you don't
have payments anymore and so i don't
want you to move backwards when you guys
have sacrificed you know you're a sharp
couple you have a great income like
let's just pay cash for this and be done
with that's the reason you saved up
forty thousand dollars not for it to sit
there but for to be put to use yeah
marion don't be embarrassed i can't tell
you how many people in my life would
tell me something like that oh it's free
money because the interest but the
reality is is the minute you get out of
nursing school the interest starts
accruing and now you've got this debt
that you're working to pay off and you
said you wanted to make more money so if
you want to make more money then go
ahead and pay it use some of that
savings get it done it's a 15 month
accelerator program now you hit the
ground running mary ann and you're
making really good money and that is
going towards replenishing savings
walking these baby steps out getting
back into that now you're investing
uh this is you don't you've got the
money don't borrow it
don't borrow it it is not a good deal
it's not gonna help you out
yeah i did not mean to shame marianne in
that call to make that very clear yeah
well george you can't raise your voice
of people i'm sorry you know how i get
i'm known for my anger and being loud
and aggressive it's great no listen i
think i think that's something a lot of
people tell i bet you she's had people
in her life that have told her that hey
it's free money
why would you use your own money borrow
other people's money opm that's how you
get wealthy ken yeah yeah it's a trap
all right hey good stuff there thank you
for the call marianne don't move more of
your calls coming up this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back america you are joining the
conversation here on the ramsey show
talking about your life your money work
your relationships i'm ken coleman
joined by joined by my colleague george
campbell and we're taking your calls
this hour triple eight eight two five
five two two five
hey when we get together as a team here
at ramsey solutions we're talking about
our mission to change america's toxic
culture in the area of money and work
and relationships and it makes us mad to
see in that money area so many people
trapped by debt or to watch kids sign
away their future for a student loan
for folks who work here this isn't a job
it's a mission if that sounds like
something you could get excited about
you got to check out all the exciting
roles at ramsey solutions because we are
looking to hire asap so let's go we need
developers ux designers and writers to
help us build digital products that
actually change people's lives to see
what it's like to do work that matters
with us before you apply follow us on
instagram and facebook by searching
ramsay careers apply for your dream job
at ramsey solutions.com
slash careers that's ramsey
solutions.com
slash careers all right sioux falls
south dakota is where we go next
zachary's there zachary how can we help
how are you guys doing we are having a
blast what's going on
um i have a question about
how
a roth ira works because i know how dave
says you can invest 6 000 a year
for 40 years that's the max and he said
it
like at 12 or something it grows to like
5.8 million so i was just wondering like
how
i don't know the rough numbers but how
exactly does it multiply
oh good question how old are you zachary
i'm 29 about to be 30 at the end of july
okay and uh have you been following the
baby steps
um
we're about to start um i'm doing every
dollar trying to work out the kinks with
that i love that app but um
it's uh
it's in the works we are do you have
debt right we're trying to do it
yeah we have debt we got um there are
there's some old debts there's there's
like one large one that's with a
collection agency that threatened to
they got a judgment on us but nothing
has ever happened with that
um
it's mostly medical bills there's two
small credit cards in there that are
they're like both under a thousand
it was like credit one and capital one
okay well i asked just to find out where
you guys are at in the in your financial
picture and i want you to use your
income because it's your greatest wealth
building tool to become wealthy and it's
hard to do that when you've got payments
in your life and so if you follow our
plan baby step one thousand dollar
starter emergency fund baby step two pay
off all of your consumer debt using the
debt snowball then we never touch debt
again then we focus on the emergency
fund three to six months of expenses in
a savings account then we can talk about
investing
so i say all that to say we're not quite
ready i love your question i'm getting
to that but i want you to know where
that falls in our plan so you don't jump
ahead of yourself right
yep i'm very familiar okay good so the
roth ira it you know when we talk about
compound interest which is what you're
talking about that works with any type
of investment i know so we talk about
good growth stock mutual funds inside of
your roth ira or roth 401k and compound
growth is fairly simple
it's when your money makes money
and so if i've got a thousand dollars in
there and i've got a 10 11 12 return
those are not numbers that we made up
out of thin air that is just tracking
the s p 500 the top 500 companies in the
stock market and that's what the numbers
have been over the inception of it back
in the uh you know the 1930s and so
when you look at that you go okay my
money can make me 10 to 12 in the market
well then that 10 to 12 percent gets
compounded every single year because
that thousand dollars turned into 1100
and now you get 12 on the 1100 and that
turns into 1500 which turned to 3 000.
so over time your contribution is a
small percentage of the actual number in
that account and so that's what happens
over time
okay
so like what happens if
someone
just puts money
into the roth ira but does not
use mutual funds does it grow
at all or oh i mean you got to put
something in there you can't just have
an op a shell of an account you've got
to actually fund that roth ira fund that
401k with something and so some people
do mutual funds that's what we recommend
you can do an index fund which is
similar you could do single stocks which
i don't recommend but with single stocks
it's going to be a lot more volatile
that's right if i just invest in tesla
and if you've seen the news tesla's real
volatile right now well i'm freaking out
i'm losing sleep at night but when i
invest in a mutual fund well that one
fund has a ton of different companies
and then when you diversify that and you
have four different types of mutual
funds you're even more diversified which
lowers your risk and so that's why we
tell people to invest in those types of
funds uh and if you do that you can
become a millionaire but you got to get
out of debt you got to have the savings
and then we can begin investing that
fifteen percent of our income into
retirement
thank you for the call zachary next we
go to raleigh north carolina rob is
there rob how can we help
good afternoon gentlemen happy friday
happy friday to you sir what's up
uh so i have an uh interesting question
for you guys i i am uh in baby steps
four five and six with our with our
family great and i know that i know the
position that you all take with respect
to
leasing vehicles
and i'm not going to try to set any new
precedent today but i do have a question
on the lease idea when it comes to
horses
my wife is
really into horses and so are my kids
when you're in baby step two you don't
get to enjoy that type of thing but now
we're in four five and six
they would like to
get a horse or or two
and uh apparently it's become popular
this in today's time to actually lease
a horse so that basically you have the
monthly payments and the upkeep but you
don't have to worry about well i guess
it depends on your contract but you
don't have to worry about
getting rid of it at the end of the day
okay hold on a second all right hold on
hold on i gotta know more because this
might shock you i know nothing about
leasing horses uh is this like a boat
thing where multiple people are using
the same boat multiple multiple people
using the same horse you get you get
larry the horse monday wednesday friday
i mean what's the deal
it is not a time share
it is uh you're actually uh you got all
so you it's only you and your family and
larry nobody else rides larry
that's it so you're just renting a horse
essentially wow
basically yeah okay well why would you
why would you why would you think i
distinguished that
the reason i distinguished that from a
vehicle right is because of the vehicle
at the end of the day you can take it to
another you know dealership and you know
they might give you cash for it a horse
is much more difficult to get rid of
yeah you know
do you know what happens to poor larry
the horse when we get rid of him it's
awful
i don't think you can say that live i
know i'm not planning to two things
everybody knows just because it's
popular doesn't mean it's not a terrible
idea eating tide pods became popular
doesn't mean we should all start doing
it
no so leasing a horse is no different a
horrible idea if you can't pay cash for
it you can't afford a horse how much
does it cost to buy a horse
no i don't think the issue is paying
cash for it i think the issue is once
you know if you need to up and leave if
you need to move you can sell the horse
you can't
okay
i mean i guess you could i guess you're
assuming that there are willing buyers
out there you're a willing buyer can i
remind you that you are willing to buy a
horse rob thought he got me there in the
corner do you not think there's other
robs out there who may want a horse yeah
who have little girls that want to ride
a horse i wouldn't plan on it being an
appreciating asset well you got to look
at this thing as a liability it's an
expense this is a hobby but if you guys
are debt-free and you want to pay cash
for a horse and deal with all the
maintenance because this is a dream of
yours i'm okay with that okay
but do not fall for this horse leasing
business it's just awful
i mean rob you're a good guy you're in
baby steps four or five and six like you
didn't think we were gonna be cool with
this did you
i didn't but it just seems different
than the vehicle i mean it's just so
rough
justification station here you're
looking for any reason to get this horse
at any cost i i got i got a little
comeback rob there was a time in the
world where horses were the only
vehicles
rob quit horsing around let's pay cash
for this there it is folks i was
wondering if you were gonna say that i
was there george campbell for the win
everybody
here to save the day james would have
killed you to pull up a horse sound to
take us out somebody in the booth got to
be thinking there's a reason they don't
let us use sound effects on the show oh
very good all right hey rob baby says
4-5-6 does not include leasing a horse
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back america this is the ramsey
show i'm ken coleman i'm joined in
studio by george campbell our verse of
the day comes from ecclesiastes 5'3
for a dream comes with much business and
a fool's voice with many words
our quote from coach mike shishesky in
recent retired from duke basketball my
hunger is not for success it is for
excellence because when you attain
excellence success just naturally
follows and that is true
uh fun last call there
great job wanting to know if he should
lease a horse and i missed the the
buzzer beater line ken when he asked
should i lease a horse and i should have
said
nay
you should not lease a horse oh yes the
dad jokes yeah i say it's really good
wow george every dull day around here
i'll tell you that much ken yeah i will
tell you had you said that real time i
would have been done you had been under
the desk you would have had to take us a
break that was just so good too many
horse puns too we're having a good time
we are so glad you're with us let's get
back to the phones philadelphia
pennsylvania kitty is there
kitty how can we help
hi george and ken how are you today we
are having a little too much fun we're
told i hear it we're horsing around
today i see that hey there we
[Laughter]
so my question for you today is um
and thank you for taking my call sure uh
my husband and i just got done uh scu a
couple about a month ago and um
which was uh a blessing because i had
tried to get him to do that for over a
year
um but he finally uh caved in and
actually enjoyed the class and now he's
like on board with me awesome my
question is we took a 401k loan out
um which we know was a big mistake now
and um so we're trying to clear that up
because really that's probably
uh 90
of what's left for our
dad hero because we're on baby step two
we paid off about 40 000 already
um since we started the class
so thank you to marketplace on facebook
because that was a big help awesome
selling stuff on there
yes selling stuff on there and just
getting rid of stuff we never use and it
was just actually it was fun because we
watched the numbers go down but now
we're stuck with this 401k loan and
not sure what to do so i made some calls
today um about getting a loan to pay off
the 401 hold on hold on kitty
what are we doing here
you're getting a loan to pay off a loan
does that not sound backwards to you
it does sound bad backwards to me and
that's what we were afraid of is that we
just stick with the 401k loan pay it off
in the five years that you know it's
recommended or
get a loan pay it off now and pay that
loan off within two years
now we've got to focus on behavior here
because right now we're just trying to
solve a problem with another problem
instead of find the solution which is
work our butts off and pay this thing
off with our cash flow with our savings
and then never touch debt again the
heloc is that we're talking about
getting a heloc
yes i believe that's what it is
a home equity line equity
it's the equity in our home
so essentially you're going to use a
credit card to pay off debt to then pay
off the credit card debt
leaving us back at square one
that's what i don't know because i'm not
very good at what equity is in your home
i'm not i'm just selling a home equity
line of credit using your home like a
credit card and you're borrowing against
your home you're putting your home at
risk the heloc is not going to create
cash flow it's just debt it's just
putting you further into debt
and so you got to save up we got to pay
cash and uh get this 401k loan paid off
what's the 401k loan what's on there how
much
uh it's like 34
okay and what's your income
uh
150. okay so what's stopping us from
using our income plus more facebook
marketplace selling to get this 401k
loan out of our life
nothing i just we just want to make sure
we
i guess it's the five year mark that's
getting me we know we're not going to be
able to pay it off
i don't understand why you would pay it
off you said earlier that it's five
years if you just pay it out of the 401k
uh paid off there versus two years with
the with the the other loan i don't
understand that math
you're just
i'm thinking
i'm sorry go ahead well you're just
moving one pile to a you know it's one
pile to another pile it just makes no
sense i'm gonna do this pile of rocks to
this side of the yard you feel like you
did something and nothing's happening
here uh you you you and your husband
need to get down
on a plan here and go okay look what can
we sell we've already we've already seen
great progress by selling things george
is right you make 150 you're gonna pay
the 34 off within a year i agree
okay and that's it there's no shortcuts
here there's no two years no five years
i think here's the fun question for you
and your husband and i mean this this is
date night what would it take for us to
pay off
that loan in one year what would it take
what would have to be true it's a great
exercise
you know what i mean because even if you
can't get to a year we might find that
we can get there in a year and a half
but what would need to be true that's a
fun exercise that's your homework what's
your take-home pay
nine thousand dollars
i'll take him um
two four six eight about almost nine
okay so you're talking about three
thousand dollars a month would get this
thing knocked out
can you live off of six thousand dollars
a month
i think we have to wait time this
thing's gone on a year and you'll come
celebrate and do your debt-free screen
with us how's that sound i mean that's
with no overtime my husband does work a
lot and let's get some overtime let's do
it in eight months let's give ourselves
a stretch goal yeah kitty we're not even
talking about your prowess on facebook
marketplace what else could you sell
that's what i'm going to do this weekend
let's get to work and let's avoid these
shortcut traps like heloc's and
consolidation you got this yeah thank
you for the call kitty come on
uh michael's up next in grand rapids
michigan michael how can we help you
hello thank you for speaking with me
today you bet what's up
um so i just kind of had a quick
question it was really more i mean money
is definitely part of it but it's really
i think more of a behavioral thing so
for a short context
me and my wife are both graduating
undergrad here in a couple weeks
and
um i have secured a post-college job
i've been working
while i've been in college we've been in
college um and
been paying our bills that way
um but
throughout the whole time that we're in
college i haven't gotten her to be able
to work um
also like
i have been helping her a lot with her
schoolwork along with doing my own
um and i i guess my kind of question is
how can i try to get i guess bring her
to the light a little bit and feel like
you know so everyone has to do something
you know like i'm to be honest i'm burnt
out we have two children i've been doing
most of the caretaking for them i've
been doing all my sport helping around
heavily with hers
working the entire time i have offers go
to law school next year and i'm i'm just
burnt out i really i'm just tired i like
sometimes i don't know like how to keep
fighting the fight or just accepts that
she's gonna be lazy and just not do
anything okay
so
uh
number one we can't answer this in the
uh a lot of time that we have number two
it's not even a behavior issue with her
it's this is a marriage issue first and
foremost
for you to sit down with a counselor and
i mean i would i would do it soon
and and you've got to share this
in in the healthy
professional space
because there's something going on here
with her
and
and then you are already to a place of
resentment
yeah
and listen resentment will eat you up
it'll eat you alive so
this is a what i would call a five-alarm
marriage fire is what this is
and i'm sitting down with a counselor
it's where i can be honest
but we got to dig and see what's going
on i will tell you this not knowing your
wife at all
i'd be willing to
guarantee you she's not lazy she's lost
and i tell you that because i think that
you've got to change the way you see
your wife going into counseling i
understand why you think she's lazy but
i don't think she's lazy i think she's
lost
and and i don't know what's causing her
to feel lost in her identity and what's
going on that's what we got to get to
the bottom of and you need help with a
professional counselor to pull that out
of her to identify that you may even
know and i'm not going to put you on the
spot and ask you to do that but
i appreciate the call and i will tell
you this is a cry for help
and i'm glad you called but let me just
tell you uh you need to have some
empathy and compassion towards your wife
as you move into this counseling session
i'm heartbroken for you michael but hang
in there don't you dare quit
george campbell thank you pal fun times
always fun to be with you thanks to our
entire team in the booth appreciate you
all i want to say thank you to america
this is your show this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you